so that's how I'm thinking of it that
upside crazy bubble Target using that
kind of everything code structure that
you know I've talked about in the past
you know we get price targets of half a
million plus so even if I discount me
for being a [__] by 50% you still get
250 Grand so that's kind of the the
spread to me 150
250 all right guys bang bang I've got Ru
here uh I thought a great place to start
is the Bitcoin ETF we get the approvals
everyone all excited and the price goes
down that's not supposed to happen why
is the price going down and what is your
reaction to the first two or three days
of trading of the Bitcoin ETF look
always the most ridiculous thing happens
in crypto I mean even the runup was the
best right that total goat rodo of the
of uh that tweet that was hacked you
know it's brilliant and it going down is
befitting basically it's the overhang
from
gbtc so there's a lot of activity lot of
repositioning net flows have been offset
really by gbtc as people are unwinding
the Arbitrage and stuff like that so I
don't think you need to read much into
it it probably has to digest don't
forget you brought brought forward a lot
of demand net net what will we brought
forward two2 three billion dollar of
demand okay so that takes time to for
the market digest and then you got to
think through who the raas are who these
people are and if you put them in your
head these are not New York dealing
rooms who getting on the phone say bye
this now there people who are wearing
slacks who read Barons on the weekend
read about the ETF aren't sure go on the
golf course see their best client he
asks them a question the whole process
is slow you know they got to go and have
steak dinners and all of that stuff so
the whole process of bringing people in
is going to take a while longer but it's
there now you know I just think of the
CTF as a a trade deal
between um V world and cryptand and so
now Capital can flow in much easier than
it used to I kind of think of this as a
mental model as like China entering the
WTO when everybody could invest in China
that's what this is now these aren't
permanent residents in
cryptand you know this is more hot money
flows you know tourism flows hot money
flows you know direct investment foreign
direct investment that's VC flows um and
then we've got a bunch of residents
there people who wallets and all of that
so I do think of it as an economy and
this just allows trade now the capital
that's going into these ETFs there's two
ways to look at it it's hey these are
the people who uh they've heard about
Bitcoin they don't really want to go set
up a coinbase account and go buy it uh
now their financial advisor saying yeah
let's allocate a little bit to it uh but
the first second that we get a 25 50%
draw down they're out of there they're
like I I knew I shouldn't have bought
that and they're gone the other argument
is that a lot of ETF uh capital is very
sticky and it's kind of like a set it
forget it and you know once that money
goes in it's likely to sit there which
one do you think is kind of a more
accurate representation of how this
Capital will behave as we get the
volatility of
Bitcoin so if you think about the
biggest buyers of this stuff is actually
the millennial cohort what the
Millennials do really well is
they um they're invest in their 401ks
every
month and they can put this in their
401ks so that's sticky that's why Arc
didn't get all the redemptions when it
went down 75% it's because it's
Millennials who own it and they put in
their 401k and they're in it for the
long ride so I think it's
the the Boomer crowd who'll be more
concerned about the volatility I think
but that's I think that's a very good
thing there can be a lot of people
putting it as a long-term asset Buy and
Hold and that should give it the
stability that you need that you don't
just get massive wash outs from people
panicking the moment it goes down and I
think most of the ETF providers have
made it pretty clear that it's a
volatile asset and it's a Buy and Hold
asset so in uh the Christian religion
there's kind of like before Jesus after
Jesus right in terms of measuring time
uh my thought process is that we're
going to have a before ETF after ETF
kind of epox of Bitcoin and specifically
talking about the volatility we had
massive asymmetry and and lots of
volatility 80% draw Downs Etc leading up
to this but if we get you said stability
that also is a pro and a con right there
if there's less volatility on the
downside I think people say that's great
but then should we also expect less
volatility to the upside as well I think
as assets mature they become less
volatile so I think we need to expect
that and particularly from passive flows
of 401k investors putting it in every
two weeks every month that'll keep a bid
that didn't exist before um so I think
yes we'll probably see lower volatility
but we'll also be feeding Capital into
cryptand and crypto is not just the
state of Bitcoin it's a whole bunch of
other places that are going to see
Capital flows so the wild west will
still exist but the big daddy becomes
less volatile which it yes it's a shame
because we can't make as much money out
of each cycle but if our underlying
philosophy is we want the adoption of
this technology to be Broad and deep it
has to go that way so it's it's kind of
good from that philosophical angle of
trying to change the world bad from the
Ridiculousness of the cycles and how
profitable Lake can be if you get them
right so we're sitting around 40,000
$42,000 today um it was at 156,000 kind
of at the bottom of the bare Market uh
what is your expectation in this bull
market will we see 100,000 150 200,000
like maybe one of the things I've taken
away is people are still looking at
these Cycles as like you know it's going
to a million dollar it's going to 500
like these crazy price predictions and I
actually may be maybe somehow I'm
getting more realistic and saying like I
don't know if we see $200,000 in the
ball Market where are you I don't know
as the answer for the same reason also
everybody's got PTSD because of last
time right that second runup after the
big correction the second run up
everybody thought it was going to extend
further and it didn't and so everyone's
got PTSD so how I'm thinking about it
I'm giving 60% probability this is a
relatively normal cycle in which case it
would get
to 150,000 let's
say I'm giving a 20% chance that it's
actually a front loed cycle because of
the ETF and other stuff that maybe it
gets to that
150 faster and then Fades which would be
kind of pain for a lot of people who
expected to go into 2025 right and then
the other 20% chance I think is that
this ends up being a bubble cycle and so
it looks more like 20112 13 than it does
the previous one and in which case if
you remember that cycle it had a interim
top correction everyone thought it was
over and then it just exploded again I
think there's a decent chance of that
but we need to see the the
contextualization of how the ETF flows
impact you know what's happening with
monetary policy what's going on in the
economy how the how the election's going
to play into this so that's how I'm
thinking of it that upside crazy bubble
T
you know using that kind of everything
code structure you know I've talked
about in the past you know we get price
targets of half a million plus so even
if I discount me for being a [__] by
50% you still get 250 Grand so that's
kind of the the the the the spread to me
150 250 um but obviously who who the
hell knows and as you know the worst
thing for any of us is everybody wants
price targets and then a year and a
half's time they hate you for it
because you went exactly right it's
ridiculous I think I think it's also
just like hey does this replicate past
you know cycles and I think that's what
everyone is thinking right um but also
maybe that is a signal that uh that's
not going to happen one but two also the
holder base has changed again right so
kind of pre-2020 there was you know the
very hardcore Believers then in 2020 we
started to get a little bit more of the
finance crowd um now I mean this is raas
this is you know as finan as it gets and
so I wonder as the price goes up do they
actually sell are they rebalancing on
the way up and so it kind of takes a
little bit of the edge off on the upside
I think that's possible but also think
about the crowd that got um
financialized in 2020 again mainly the
millennial crowd right there's 110
million coinbase accounts and when I
checked six months ago only 9 million
were
active So speaking to the guys at
coinbase they're like yeah you know in
normal activity it'll get to 35 40
million and the top will grow as well so
there's a lot of money still to come in
of people who participated last time
around have that interest still have
PTSD will come back in so maybe that
offsets it I don't know um I also have a
feeling the applications layer of of
blockchain is going to bring in a lot
more use case so I'm thinking of this
cycle is maybe the everything everywhere
all at one cycle when people have
different unlocks for nfts or
descriptions or different unlocks for um
smart contracts and some of the other
things and they can use it for
everything from whether it's ticketing
to real world assets so it it just
depends how far the applications layer
goes if the applications layer doesn't
make much progress this cycle then
you're dead right you know we'll see
rebalancing don't forget they're also
going to be
issuing um options on the
ETF and that changes the structure of
markets as well explain that more
because I don't think a lot of people
understand uh maybe the the uh blessing
and the curse of this ETF
approval yeah so what you've done and it
was always going to happen is bitcoin's
now become financialized when it wasn't
really it was still had Purity to it now
it doesn't mean it's impure because of
this but you've allowed a
financialization layer and what that's
going to mean is that they are going to
offer leverage products on it now
options are are kind
of defined risk products but what you
end up with is in a very high volatility
product we get a lot of volatility
Sellers and it dampens the market
because they're always hedging and that
hedging
structure um can really change the
nature of Market sometimes it creates
acceleration points because everybody's
short and suddenly the price goes
through and everyone has to buy
everything back other times just by the
ongoing
selling of yield you know selling of
premium for yield uh it slows down the
whole Market itself um so I do think
that's a bigger deal than people expect
um but the casino for options on ETFs is
going to be quite amusing for a while as
well because you know if you think about
how many how much the Robin Hood crowd
use options on uh tech stocks they're
going to go wild on this stuff and
they've not been able to you know for
Americans it was really hard you know
derit was not accessible to Americans
they're now going to start using options
what I don't know when that launches but
it'll happen at some point and that
brings in all the market making firms
and the investment Banks and all of
these other Financial players one of the
other aspects that obviously drives
price of not only Bitcoin but most
assets around the world is liquidity and
interest rates and um I maybe a shocking
thing if I had said to you in the
beginning of 2020 uh hey they're going
to cut interest rates and asset prices
are going to rise you'd say okay that
makes sense but then if I told you at
the end of 2021 they're going to raise
the interest rates to you know 5 and a
half% and the stock market's still going
to go to an all-time high bitcoin's
going to go up you know hundreds of perc
off the bottom I think a lot of people
be like that doesn't make any sense like
how it can interest rates be higher but
also asset prices are still continuing
to grow what's happening there so this
is the difficulty people have with um
different time
Horizons so interest rates are set by
the Federal Reserve the Federal Reserve
operates in
core inflation land which is driven by
um core inflation unemployment which is
driven by stuff like owner equivalent
rents and stuff all of this stuff is
lagged so the FED operating that that
lags stuff like crypto and tech stocks
are trading on liquidity and future
liquidity so Financial conditions they
ease the long time ago so people looking
at the FED saying well when the FED
raise or when the FED cut that's not
relev relevant what's actually relevant
is what the kind of financial conditions
are doing which have been loosening
massively and liquidity has been rising
whether you use fed net liquidity or
broader measures or M2 they're all
Rising on a global basis and the global
base is another key thing most people
Miss because they kind of look at the us
only but you know if if we look at this
cycle who's got the biggest economic
problems right now is China so they
probably have the biggest bazooka to
fire to try and get their economy going
then it's the Europeans then the
US you know it feels that way but we've
seen liquidity you know I managed to
catch the bottom in crypto and Tech last
year because of liquidity had bottomed
and the moment it bottomed eth bottom
first and then the whole Space bottomed
including Tech in October um and it's
just been following that liquidity cycle
ever since and using my forward-looking
projections based around this everything
code thesis you know it should continue
all the way into
2025 um and crypto should continue to
price that what is the everything code
today's episode is brought to you by
espresso the maker of the world's
thinnest portable display now listen up
if you're like me you feel like you are
at a command center when you sit down at
your desk I got a gazillion tabs open
and different windows for different
activities there's my web browser my
text messages I've slack open and I got
a Notes app I normally work on a desktop
and it can be very very productive but
everything falls apart the second I
leave my desk if I'm traveling I go to a
coffee shop to do some work or just want
to work from the kitchen table my laptop
doesn't have enough screen space I lose
my command center and my productivity
falls off a cliff it's a major problem
but this is where espresso comes in they
have a portable screen that is so
beautiful that you think Steve Jobs came
back from the dead to create it the
thing is incredibly light it comes with
a nice stand and the user interface is
so easy that I figured out how to do it
in less than 3 minutes if you listen to
this podcast you know that's not an easy
feat so the espresso team and I we
became friends I got to know them cuz I
really like the product and those
screens they now want to offer them to
any fan of the podcast so we struck a
little deal here's how it works anyone
who listens to this podcast can go to
us.
P.O or that's too confusing just go
click the link in the description if you
go to espresso's website they've got a
brand new offer there sitting for you
you get a little discount and you'll get
a beautiful screen trust me I use mine
every day you'll love the espresso
screen and I think it'll make you more
productive go check them out today by
clicking on the link in the description
the everything code is a thesis that I
put together after 30 years of work
where it came randomly we kind of all
know the world's broken there's all the
debt and the demographics and stuff you
and I have talked about many
times I started looking at the ism the
business cycle so the instiute supply
manager survey and it was like [__]
Clockwork every four years and that kind
of stopped me in my tracks like this
didn't exist beforehand
and then I realized that what had
happened in 2008 was a debt Jubilee
where every Central Bank said we'll cut
rates to zero so you don't need to pay
the interest think of it in those terms
because there was too much debt so every
government around the world resets their
debt to three to fiveyear sector and
that leads to this four-year cycle which
is the same as the presidential cycle
and it's the same as the Haring cycle
cuz big was born out of that right so
everything is now perfectly
cyclical and that won't change until we
solve the debt
problem and once you understand that you
can then forward look um where liquidity
is going to go because if if we're
repeating the same cycle you just use
the old cycle map it forwards for ISM
and it gives you a forward look on
assets um and if that's the case then
it's a real code now what I found within
this was that the use of the balance
sheet by all of the central banks was
just for one thing to pay the interest
on the debt of the previous
cycle so they are just abasing the
currency in the purest simplest form
which is why we all make so much money
out of crypto because it does the best
because it's got technological
adoption and it's it's a scarce asset so
it does phenomenally well when they
debase so liquidity comes in that's
great debasing the currency is super
great and so they we've now got coming
forwards if we if we look forwards we've
now got all the covid interest payments
to make you cannot do them at 5 and a
half percent we saw that before the bond
market freaked out there's no way you
can Finance it without all the debt
payments going exponential so the FED
have to bring rates down and it's going
to end up on the central bank balance
sheet as it always does because there's
no other way because
if you think about how the world works
is GDP growth Trend GDP growth in the US
is
1.75% the government's 100% of GDP in
debt it's actually more but but easy
maths if interest rates are 5% that's 5%
of GDP that needs to pay the
interest but growth is only growing at
1.75 so you'd have negative growth oh
but the private sector is another 100
and something per of GDP in
so they're competing for the same GDP to
pay the interest so something has to
give and what gives is the government
side ends up on the balance sheet so
this was all this big thesis I found
from the everything code that made
everything explainable why asset prices
rise why is it becoming predictable why
have we got these Cycles uh and what's
really going on which is the debasement
and debasement to think about they're
doing it about 15% a year on
average so they could have either raised
tax taxes by
15% um to get the payments which is
politically unacceptable in an age like
now so instead they just clip the coins
and debase the currency and people don't
really notice they just notice that the
rich get richer because they can afford
scarce assets and the poor get left
behind which is creating this huge
political divide as well how do you
think measuring inflation is done best
by the average person is it asset prices
is it CPI is it something like a true
inflation is it something else like when
you try to get at what is the actual
inflation rate what do you look at so I
think there's I think there's two
inflations and each person has a
different inflation your inflation rate
is different than mine but I think
there's two inflations one is the
inflation versus your income which is
what we saw last year so the cost of
goods Rises faster than your income so
you have less discretionary spending
power right that's what caused the
economic slowdown that was the [__] show
that happened in 2021
2022 asset inflation is different your
future self is poorer what an asset is
is a way of tying up your capital in
something with an expected return so in
a future date you're hoping to be
wealthier the issue is there so with
this regular inflation which I don't
think is sticky I think it falls back
again doesn't mean that prices don't
come down the prices come down but the
rate of inflation comes down this asset
inflation is more pentious and it's the
thing that people don't understand you
know if you go and speak to your parents
and say you know how many times your
income could would it cost to buy a
house when they were in their mid-30s
they would say three times four times
you ask a 35y old now how many times
your income would buy a house it's like
10 12 14 15 times right so they future
selfs support because they can't buy
that house house I think that is more
destructive over the long
run they're both destructive but this is
bad yeah I I completely agree um you
also have this uh new motto phrase uh
don't [__] this up what is that and what
what is that really I think kind of
reinforcing to people as we go into 2024
and
2025 look you've been around this for a
long time we've all made the mistake and
everybody makes mistakes it's very hard
dealing with an asset let's say crypto
that
is very volatile but when it runs it
really runs and and you become
overwhelmed by
emotion fomo you see your friends bought
that 100x dogcoin and you're like I want
some of that you want to look for 100xs
as opposed to just own some Bitcoin and
if you want to own some eth and if you
know a few of the big projects and just
buy and hold but people don't do it they
want to start trading it because they
think they can make more money um also
they custody things wrong people start
thinking I want the extra 5% yield by
sticking into some project of which they
know nothing about the security of and
the don't [__] this up is don't let
somebody take your
tokens don't
trade and hold quality assets if you can
do that with 90% of your portfolio you
will do well keep 10% to be a total
filthy Degen do what the hell you want
because that will go to zero we've all
got the wallet of Shame right every
single one of us has a wallet of Shame
of shrapnel left from the previous cycle
that didn't do anything so don't [__] it
up it's trying to protect people from
themselves and so we've actually even
issued an nft which is free so it's in
your wallet and it's a video of me
saying don't [__] this up so when people
go in their wallets there's me looking
at them disapprovingly trying to say
look don't [__] this up so if people
want to do that you also get the um
subscription to the uh the free
subscription to the real Vision platform
but it's free so go to real.com pomp get
the do not [__] this up don't [__] this
up nft it's free but it's the most
valuable nft you'll have because it'll
stop you doing the stupid [__] that you
know you'll do when you lose your mind I
love it so I'm just trying to help
people is really in the essence I'm
trying to help people because I think we
maybe got two more Cycles left at best
and this is a game Cher and as we talked
about most young people can't
afford you know they've got they' now
starting to have kids they got kids
schooling University they can't afford a
house if they do they have to move miles
outside uh further away they just they
can afford less of the S&P than their
parents could all of that stuff so like
here is the chance to increase your
probability ility of your future self
living up to that image you've got which
is people want a comfortable retirement
they want their kids to go through
school they want a house to live in they
want to be able to pay their medical
bills well if you just don't [__] this
up you can do that it's not a guarantee
but it's a but there's a high chance so
the message that you're sharing is
shared in a very specific way we also
now are seeing uh other people enter the
space and share their message their
advertising their marketing in a very
specific way um most notably black rocks
new commercial is basically a guy who is
standing there no tie but the Blazer the
jacket the nice like almost like a
elevator music playing in the background
and it literally if you're don't even
listen to what he says he's you just
know it's okay black Rock's here we got
you it is now okay to buy this
ETF which is in direct opposition from
pretty much every other issuers ads
which have been all about Innovation and
disruption and you know Bitcoin ethos
Etc
do we need both or will the Black Rock
style approach actually suck in a ton of
capital that maybe the others couldn't
actually reach so I think it's a matter
of
demographics which demographic you're
trying to reach so if you Vanek you're
trying to reach young people right
Fidelity Abigail Johnson's made it very
clear in Fidelity that she wants to um
attract young people and give them the
products that they need for their
financial success so that that's why
those guys tend to skew younger black
rock is going for that classic
Raa mutual fund from Ohio kind of
product and that's exactly the right
messaging that they need so I think it's
look as you know this product Bitcoin
itself is so disruptive and so
broad-based that it needs multim
messaging it can't just be it's digital
gold it can't just be you know this is a
new system it has to be a number of
different narratives and actually I know
there's a big philosophical hand ringing
about an ETF and is this really what we
signed up for I just think of it as the
trade deal we're bringing Capital into
the space to finance new
projects and that allows us to move the
whole thing forwards and when you hear
Larry thinkink talking about the
tokenization of all assets you know it's
moving forwards and the more Capital
that comes into the space the more
people can build
so yes it's it's
suboptimal but we need that capital from
fat world and get it into cryptand so we
can create this new system we all want
so I want to push further into the
industry if you're a Bitcoin maximalist
you can shut off the episode now because
we're g to talk about things you don't
like um in terms of uh you know kind of
pushing a little bit further out on the
risk curve I think that there is a
debate between ethereum salana and a
plethora of new Challengers that are
coming uh up how do you think about
technology and is there going to be kind
of win or take all on the technology
front and then how do you think about
Capital allocation from an investor seat
and do you own you know both or more do
you own one do you try to predict how
are you thinking about those two things
it's bloody hard right so it's fine when
you get through the second cycle that's
why you know I was I'm I'm very
overweight salana because I could say it
survived the worst nuclear winter and
the developers were very active the
community was very active and then they
made some big Tech breakthroughs with
being able to Mint a million nfts for
100 bucks and then fire dancer which
kind of changes the entire game again in
terms of speed and cost so I think so
that you know that's why I backed that
horse and still having Bitcoin and still
having um
ethereum and then there's a bunch of new
stuff you know how did sui and say
and po gone and there's just so many
things and the answer is I don't know
it's difficult you know that's one of
the reasons I set up the asset
management business I've got exponential
age asset management was because this
bit is difficult it's easy to own the
top three or four and not [__] it up
it's very difficult to choose the
winners unless you're in it all day
understanding everything and so the idea
I have was to start an asset management
business that just invests in crypto
hedge funds so it's a funder fund so
they actually are doing the work to find
that because it's otherwise it's
actually really difficult to do and
again we've all got proof in our wallets
that we thought we were on to the next
big thing and it wasn't but in terms of
is it a win or takes all I I just think
we can't
tell I I doubt it I doubt it I think
different things will be different
chains will be used for different things
but it'll probably end up being a total
of five take 80% of the
market so what's also interesting to me
is if you go and you take a look at uh
maybe tokens or chains that everyone you
know has laughed at and think is uh
somewhat stupid um you can see that over
the last uh year let's call it Tron is
up 82% all time it's up uh 5,400 per. if
you were to go talk to people in the
crypto Community most of them for a very
long time would be like what nobody uses
that Etc the reason why it's interesting
is because it's actually the most
popular blockchain for stable coins
that's right and so there is a very big
Divergence
between the like data and like what is
actually being adopted from a use case
standpoint and then what I would call
the investment case so this one seems to
be dispelling The Narrative of nobody
uses that because obviously it's the
most popular for stable coins but it
hasn't necessarily outperformed from a
financial perspective just owning
Bitcoin or any of these other assets and
so to your point there's a complexity of
not only understanding where is usage
happening where developers Etc but that
doesn't always necessarily translate to
the best returns either so you have to
really balance some of these things and
kind of think through that complexity I
mean xrp is another one it has use
there's plenty of use but it's it's not
the best performing asset it's just it's
a blockchain that gets used uh there's a
bunch of others
with with big market caps that aren't
used at all
just for for fun I mean you could use
Doge I it's just I mean Elon may use
Doge for payment systems or whatever
some way shape or form but do got huge
market cap just driven by retail
investors it's bananas but you know this
is the space we're in how do you think
about uh investing in the memes so I
talked to Joe mccan and one of the big
things he basically talks about is you
know I me it's very kind of George Soros
ask right in the sense of like when you
see the bubble Rush In And these memes
take hold uh in crypto in some weird way
it feels like people not only are
willing to share the meme uh they're
willing to kind of signal they're part
of a group but also uh because they've
seen 100x thousand X so many times then
once they're in the meme they almost
become like the cult member they really
hold right like they believe it is going
which has that reflexive uh kind of
drive on the price so how much of you
know maybe the the work that you all do
in in terms of investing is like I'll
call it quotequote fundamentals
Developers chain activity Etc versus
understanding more of like the meme
landscape and and kind of where capital
is going to flow based on the narratives
this episode is brought to you by frck
historically the wealthy had a hidden
secret in investing they would spend a
lot of money and use very big teams to
conduct tax loss harvesting tax loss
harvesting is the timely selling of
Securities at a loss to offset the
amount of capital gains tax owed from
selling the profitable assets later but
now frk is bringing this incredible
advantage to any investor they'll
literally lower your tax bill regardless
of how much money you have they use
state-of-the-art technology through a
product called direct indexing to allow
investors to invest in the S&P 500 while
getting all the benefits of tax loss
harvesting without the big Bill if you
want to learn more go check them out at
frk.com that's
fc.com I'm a big fan of the product and
I even became an investor in the
business frk.com go check them out today
listen I think the whole Space the meme
is really important I mean the best meme
Bitcoin ever had was not digital gold
it's number go up right I mean that's
such a powerful meme right and people
get it and so memes are really important
because these are new things and people
don't know how to really place them in
in the mental
framework but
then it's kind of a child of the
internet too so you know dog with hat is
like the big meme coin of the moment um
and that's fine it's kind of pure
speculation and culture it's the value
of culture and but the problem is it can
die so quick the culture of one thing
and others are pervasive like Doge so it
it is really hard to do but my God you
can make a lot of money and in my 10%
djm portfolio I've got a couple of those
um that are just memes I think could
work but it actually takes a lot of work
so a few of my friends are really good
at doing this they really focus on the
meme um try and look at the meme that
might run for a year or a year and a
half as opposed to the meme because some
of these will do 50x in a month and then
disappear so it's again it's hard and I
don't like people to do it unless they
really know what they're doing or if do
do it with the 10% because that's one
way of [__] it
up you just think you're on to the next
100x you put all your cash in you get
rug pulled or whatever and before you
know it you've lost all your money
another uh maybe investment strategy or
idea um that I've been thinking a lot
about is the public market uh obviously
has now turned and realized well if
these crypto assets are going to run
then companies in that industry probably
are going to do pretty well as well and
we've seen the public miners outperform
Bitcoin we've seen coinbase outperform
Bitcoin over the last you know 12 13
months um I don't know if that continues
to happen or not but if you dig into
that a little bit further it seems like
the public market still does not quite
yet understand crypto native revenue and
I'll give you maybe three examples one
being uh coinbase you understand the
exchange Revenue you understand the
custody Revenue but then they have the
new blockchain base and there's a bunch
of Revenue that's coming from there and
if you don't quite understand that
crypto native component you may actually
miss and under um you know expect what
coinbase could do because of that
Revenue miners if they're Mining and the
price of Bitcoin goes up 2X and nothing
else changes the revenue in dollars will
go up 2x because the revenue is
denominated in Bitcoin so so again kind
of a Crypton native component and then a
lot of these Asset Management firms
they're not just making money on let's
call it you know 50 basis points or 100
basis points if they have assets that
are involved in staking or other types
of activity there's additional Revenue
that they're able to derive which again
if you just use the Legacy kind of
traditional framework you would miss in
terms of underwriting this and so how do
you think about public market investing
in crypto related equities given kind of
what we've seen so
far um so firstly now the ETF is out
maybe some of these things don't
outperform but some of them naturally do
miners do like because it's the same
with gold miners if once the gold price
goes up and you cover the cost of
electricity before you know they start
compounding money the ETF will mean some
of those flows get taken away so people
don't use proxies so stuff like micro
strategies might trade at a slight
discount um but I think you're right the
market doesn't yet because the
investment Banks didn't do the research
on this stuff so it all flows down from
the authentication by the investment
banks that flows down to the asset
management firms who then decide to
allocate and that's been thin on the
ground because they've not really
touched crypto so I do think there's a
as more companies come public I know
Circle probably the next one there'll be
a bunch of these coming public um and I
think that means that the investment
banks will treat it as a full sector and
then they will start advising clients
and so we will understand these things
better maybe they all get repriced in
this cycle to a better ricing
strategy what about nfts I know you've
been pretty bullish on those over time
uh what do you think about that market
and kind of where that's going so nfts
are just
assets um that lag if you think of Arts
nfts right the expensive stuff like or
the punk behind
me that stuff is a function of
discretionary
income much like Rolex watches have been
going
down as has Fine Wine as has secondhand
cars as has nfts punks and I chart all
of this stuff and look at them and they
just lag the economy because right now
markets aren't at all-time highs people
don't have they don't want to start
social signaling yet by buying the
fantasy Rolex or the punk or whatever so
it just so I think we've been bottoming
for a while in those assets but I think
nfts this cycle I think we will see and
you and I talked about this before uses
stuff like ticketing you know just scale
uses of smart contracts um I think we
will see that because the technology now
enables it so it doesn't have to be
super expensive we've also seen the rise
of inscriptions and ordinals and that
kind of stuff which is really
interesting and right now we're just in
the experiment ation phase but people
will figure out okay what really needs
to be inscribed on the Bitcoin
blockchain versus what doesn't need to
be that kind of stuff and I I think it's
really
interesting now when you look at these
nfts what do you expect the use case to
be like art obviously was the kind of
first use case that really took off is
it just hey Art on a blockchain or do
you think that it's more of kind of
memberships and and things like that or
or maybe something
else so with the new salana compress
nfts and I know others have similar
stuff basically they're cheaper than
printing a physical
ticket so now you're going to a baseball
game your tickets an nft you can't go to
the event you can sell it instantly okay
you're releasing tra trapped
Capital hotel rooms another thing you
know we all booked hotel rooms and
sudden we have to cancel the trip the
hotel won't give you your money back
they lose out because nobody's having a
glass of wine and a steak in their
restaurant you've lost out because
you've lost your entire money if it's an
nft you could have a market place and
you can exchange the hotel rooms so I
think it's going to release a lot of
trap Capital out of ticketing stuff like
that outside of just the cultural stuff
we can use it for you know I don't see
any reason why album covers from from
music artists because they're free of
all the IP issues of Music which is a
nightmare but the album cover art
why can't those be nfts so Taylor Swift
can can both monetize it or reward
people for it so look I think there's a
lot of use cases and nfts really if
they're just smart contracts well that
means all OTC options should be um
nfts insurance contract be nfts that's
basically what Larry fin is talking
about and kind of tokenizing all these
different assets um people have been
around a while remember in 2017 I mean I
was beating the drum like look all this
stuff is going to get tokenized and I
think uh after meeting with tons and
tons of Institutions I was like oh it's
going to happen in 15 years right like
like there was no path in the short term
um what do you think like do all of
these assets get tokenized and we should
expect you know um stocks bonds
currencies Commodities and everything in
between will eventually be uh when I
first got into Bitcoin
2013 this was my thesis and here we are
10 years later and it was the last thing
to happen when I thought it was the most
obvious first thing to happen I thought
the financial system's going to be first
but regulation inertia and fear has been
the real thing um so they've waited for
something bigger to be built and now
people are understanding it and I think
things like I I don't think people
understand this salana fire dancer and
again not just picking on salana um
because I'm long of it but it's just
like they're thinking that Sal 's
theoretical TPS is
65,000 biod Daner takes it to 1
million and it was built by jump trading
and the idea is you can therefore use
blockchain for high frequency trading so
therefore it can be used for all
exchanges and if you think about the
mess of FTX we need exchanges on
blockchain we need the recorded
ownership of assets when Leman Brothers
went under everybody's got a claim on
the collateral and the 35 claims on the
same piece of collateral right this
sorts it all out automatic settlement of
everything we've seen that in defi defi
is a great experiment in showing that
everything can automatically settle and
contracts can resolve so it it is coming
and it feels that once you speak to
Franklin Templeton Fidelity the people
at JP Morgan black rock that they are
working towards it um you know but
there's been some setbacks as well
Australia tried tried to put their Stock
Exchange on blockchain Rails and gave
up you know there's a bunch of people
who tried and given
up you um sit inside of what I'll call
the billionaire circle of all these
great macro uh folks who grew up
together um what are they talking about
we saw you know ptj and D come out in
2020 and said they owned Bitcoin um
we've seen the Allen Howards of the
world you know multiple times and kind
of the uh moves that their firm has made
uh we can go down the list of many many
others are they excited right now are
they sitting on their hands uh I'm
starting to get phone calls okay which
is interesting right once you start to
get the phone calls because there's a
bunch of them that deep in the space
like Allan um he's deep in the space
bunch of them have people who are
already operating you know this bucket
for them so you know they're always
around you know the Paul Joneses and the
uh um Stan Rock and Millers they'll be
periodically in and out you know they're
they're agnostic they they get it but
they they're Traders you got the lewiis
bacons of this world who have teams of
doing people doing stuff as do a bunch
of them um but then there's the other
kind of billionaire crowd which is the
other hedge fund managers or just the
general billionaire crowd and a lot of
them came into it for the first time
last
cycle had they metal tested um like God
this is not easy but I know they'll be
back so that's I'm getting quite a few
phone calls from that crowd as well
which is like hey should we get back in
and what should I be thinking and how
should I be doing it um you know what
does this all mean so I think that
they'll all be back in and I think this
time around they'll stay um because now
they understand it you've got to go
through a cycle to understand how this
asset works so I think they'll stay this
time around and they'll figure out how
to deal with it and um I think Alan
Howard uh maybe um or or brevan Howard
in Allen but uh they look at this as
like the fifth sleeve of macro if you go
and you talk to uh a Dr or a ptj they
also are not changing their framework of
being a macro investor this is now just
getting plugged in to that framework is
that kind of what you're seeing across
the board as people are saying look I'm
a macro investor this is just now part
of that you know playing field yeah and
I've done a lot of work from this from
Global macro investor which a lot of
these guys are all subscribers to and
I've basically
proven that crypto is a macro asset it's
driven by the same forces of
liquidity and you relentlessly show that
there's a narrative which is like this
is funny internet money blah blah blah
and you show them it's exactly the same
forces so you can use Global M2 or
liquidity whatever thing and then you
start proving okay how do you use the
same macro
tools and chosen different assets what
are the outcome and you find that even
on a risk adjusted basis crypto is like
five or 10 or 20x better it's like that
I think you tweeted it out as well
Fidelity put that hilarious scatterplot
of risk rewards of all the assets and
all bottom left and then you kind of
don't realize but you have another look
and right up at the top right is Bitcoin
that's right it's ridiculous it looks
like a pit Anonymous account on Twitter
made it as a joke like it can't
I know I know and it's crazy but it's
true and I just I wrote about it again
in global macro investor this month just
showing using different measures of risk
reward how good it is so I've banged
that drum so people now realize okay I
don't need to be scared of it because
it's driven by the same macro cycle if
it's the same macro cycle then anybody
can trade it and once you understand
that then it's just a matter of okay how
much how much allocation do I want to
the volatility
makes uh makes complete sense my last
question for you is uh outside of the
billionaire uh class what about the
institutions themselves uh what do you
see there whether it is uh kind of LP
style uh you know type allocators or uh
maybe even some of um you know the very
large hedge funds that we don't know
about that are so far you know
interested in
this I think the main driver of this
whole space in terms of private Capital
has been family
offices because they don't have a
mandate they can do what they want so
we've seen and continue to see the
family offices Drive the VC business and
the hedge fund
industry the institutions are still few
and far between you know the guys at um
Texas
teachers um there there's only a few
that have really allocated nobody's done
a big
allocation there's a lot of noise that
the Middle East is doing stuff but I
don't see many people actually coming
back with tickets so I think that's
still to
come um it feels that you know because
if you think about how the world works
even when when we look at from
xam the hedge fund side none of the
hedge funds are on like the Cambridge
Associates platforms and the big
platforms they just haven't done crypto
so the traditional way of some giant
pension fund going to Cambridge
Associates finding what the right hedge
funds are and having Cambridge do the
due diligence and then allocating
doesn't exist right now so they don't
really have a way of doing it unless
you've got some sort of pioneers within
the shop
itself so it still feels like the major
institutions of that type we'll see more
this time around you we saw reasonable
am last time we'll see more this time
around it's probably the cycle after
that I think the ETF is a good thing
because I know there's a lot of Rogue
fun fund managers who know that they can
Hoodwink the risk manager by saying I've
just got an equity it's called it I bit
it's an equity you don't know what it is
and it's Bitcoin right they will do that
there'll be a bunch of people who do
that and eventually they'll get the
mandates to do it properly I do think
that a huge source of inflows for the
Bitcoin ETF uh spot ETF is going to be
other ETFs just putting the Bitcoin ETF
in their portfolio like I don't know
what the numbers are um but if you're
out there with a mutual fund or an ETF
and it's been lagging what better thing
to do than put the best risk adjusted
asset possible into your portfolio even
if it's a 2% 5% allocation right it
doesn't have to be
huge but it'll return I think that's
what Black Rock and Fidelity will do
because they run these broad portfolio
mandates um and they will show the um
the acreative benefits of having Bitcoin
in a portfolio and so what they'll
automatically start doing is adding 2%
or whatever to client portfolio so
that's part of that ongoing bull flows
analysis and we saw this
um back in the late '90s when uh Goldman
built these
gsci commodity um products nobody had
Commodities in their portfolio they were
too volatile nobody wanted them cut a
few years later there's like a 100
billion of them have been bought by
institutions where can we send people to
find you online or uh look at a global
macro investor yeah so you can find me
on Twitter uh Ral GMI uh
and then there's links there to all of
the other stuff like go micro investor
if your um real vision is where you get
yourself educated you know we've done a
lot together people should go there it's
free we've built this incredible new
platform with built-in AI automated
transcripts um this whole chat tool with
this globe spinning we can meet members
all around the world all sorts of cool
[__] and it's free to go to realvision
tocom Pomp and there you can get that
don't [__] this up nft with me in your
wallets trying to save from yourself
which I think is
priceless amazing thank you so much for
doing this and we'll definitely do it
again in the future absolutely my friend
good to see you